so we've had a bunch of people send in
the question why together is better my
new book together is better is only
available in hardcover and will it be
available in digital format well when we
had the opportunity to produce this book
I'm writing something called together as
better it's about interpersonal
relationships it's about the real world
it's about smelling and seeing and
touching and hearing the world around us
and so I thought what an amazing thing
to do to produce a book that you smell
and touch and see and it's physical and
it's in the real world and as many of
you know we had a custom sent design the
smell of optimism that is in the book
this is unreadable in a digital format
it's Illustrated which we could do in a
high def digital format but we can't do
it in your standard nook or Kindle in
other words the goal is produced to
produce something physical and beautiful
something that we want to give to
someone receiving an e-book as a gift
doesn't mean as much as receiving a
physical book I said yes so that's the
reason we did it so it still begs the
question is it gonna come out in digital
format well to be honest with you
I haven't made up my mind yet if there's
a lot of demand and if we see that
there's a potential for somebody to get
the message through a digital means I'm
absolutely open to it however I will
only do it in a full-color format where
you have to have some sort of Kindle
Fire or iPad or something like that in
order to enjoy it because I still want
the richness of the illustrations and
all the color that goes with them to be
a part of the experience I would forego
the smell but not the whole experience
so that's the reason it's currently only
available in hardcover because it's
really nice to touch and see and turn
the pages and smell and hand to another
person and say you inspire me thank you
so that's why I did it